foreign
foolishness so you understand wisdom by
understanding foolishness and you
understand wisdom foolishness as not
identical to ignorance these are the
moves you have to make to get the chess
pieces on the board if you want to play
the game we're going to play right and
so
foolishness what is it what do we mean
by this
and this is an idea that's born in the
axial Revolution the specific notion of
foolishness but this this idea and I
think foreign Bears it out I argue about
it I publish about it the very processes
that make us intelligent problem solvers
make us so adaptive
are the very same processes that make us
prone to self-deceptive self-destructive
Behavior
you don't get one without the other
so you use your intelligence to solve
problems but you use rationality and
wisdom to deal with the self-deception
that emerges as you're trying to solve
your problems and that's a very
different thing and the thing about
these self-deceptions is they don't come
as sort of isolated little things they
they can constellate into complex
patterns of self-organization you know
the confirmation bias can strengthen
egocentrism of which can strengthen the
degree to which you engage in a kind of
narrow framing of situations which can
then feed back into the confirm and you
and we've published on this right you
get these massively complex so that
the dynamical complex self-organization
of your cognition is hijacked by
self-deceptive processes and they form
these systems that are also complex and
adaptive and hard to intervene on we
call it parasitic processing in the work
that Leo and I published right John
would you mind giving an example because
there are people listening I'm sure a
lot of people listening who Pride
themselves on being good problem solvers
Strong having strong analytical minds
and they're like yeah but I don't see
how that automatically begets
or not automatically but how that would
be good delusion self-deception okay
would you mind giving an example real or
hypothetical oh well let's use a chess
example okay so here's the problem
facing you in chess you can't actually
check all the possible
alternative Pathways for playing a chess
game the number of alternative Pathways
is greater than the number of atomic
particles in the universe so even the
super fastest chess game can't check all
of the possible alternative sequences of
actions
that means that's why by the way you
know you get a chess game that beats any
human being or let's do it with go you
get
alphago beats in a human being but then
you can make a machine that beats
alphago because no AI can
algorithmically play and search so what
we have to do is we have to bias what
information we check
this is the Paradox it sounds like a Zen
Cohen right you're intelligent because
of your ability to ignore so much
information in a way that makes obvious
to you the relevant information enough
of the time that you're a very good
Problem Solver in very many many domains
so you're playing chess what's a good
heuristic control the center board I've
played with somebody who is controlling
the center board I realized that they
were biasing their attention that way
and so I played a peripheral game and
beat them because they focused on now
should people not focus on the center
board well no it's a very good heuristic
but it's heuristic it's not an algorithm
this is this is a formal thing it's
called the no free lunch theorem there
is no problem solving method that will
universally solve all your problems in
fact the area above
the line of average problem solving
where it's improving your performance is
equal to an area under the line where it
degrades your performance every bias is
just a heuristic misfiring and every
heuristic is just a bias that happens to
be working for us in a lot of contexts
they're interchangeable together and so
even when you're doing analytic stuff
you're confronting this you'll often
realize the way you frame the problem is
actually what's preventing you from
solving the problem you have to have
that aha moment that breaks you out of
it but when you're trapped in it that's
that's a form of self-deception you
can't really lie to yourself what you do
is you you bias your attention to find
the wrong thing Salient in a way that
binds you to trying to solve it in a
particular manner this shows up in
interpersonal context I'm sure you had
something like this as an experience
oh oh
I thought she was angry but she's afraid
she's afraid not angry I've been going
at this all wrong
right but that doesn't mean that
sometimes people aren't angry at you and
you shouldn't see them as angry at you
right right and so
even the most analytic thing you're
doing is dependent on
pure logic you're going in to do a logic
class this is from my history and a lot
of people will back me up on this
for a while what you're doing is you're
practicing doing all the Machinery of
the Transformations and the logic trees
and all the derivations you just got to
practice that and then you realize but
I'm still not getting like really I'm
still only getting B's and lower A's
like what's going on and you keep
getting docked not on the logic but how
you translate it natural language into
the logic for which there is no logical
procedure right and and so you that
translation process right is needed in
order to get the logical Machinery
running but it is not itself governed in
a purely logical manner it requires this
flexibility this reframing this Insight
this kind of stuff